ambiance chaleureuse en revanche pour le
premier voyage officiel du président de
la république jacques chirac au maroc
avec une visite symbole aujourd'hui à la
mosquée de casablanca sur place philippe
harrouard et jacques gérard leroy et le
président une amitié qui marche
la france met en avant le rôle
modérateur est acquis du tout 20 euros
qu'un sur la scène internationale
surtout dans le processus de paix au
proche orient
de même qu'elle soutient les efforts de
la san 2 pour encourager un islam modéré
et tolérant symbole la grande mosquée de
casablanca construite sur l'océan
car le trône de dieu était sur l'eau dit
le coran c'est l'un des plus importants
édifices religieux du monde inauguré il
ya deux ans le président chirac a visité
cette merveille architecturale qui marie
les techniques les plus modernes à la
plus pure tradition marocaine 35 mille
artisans ont participé à sa décoration
la salle de prière peut accueillir 25
mille fidèles le toit de 1100 tonnes
souvent en cinq minutes
c'est spirituel est vraiment à l'honneur
à la fois du maroc de l'humanité doit
faire avec jacques chirac la france a
décidé de privilégier le maroc et son
pôle de stabilité dans la région
la france soutiendra les efforts
économiques d'un pays qui s'est ouvert
récemment à la démocratie même si c'est
loin d'être parfait